[Music]
what's going on guys
Netflix the defenders recently dropped
all four of their street-level heroes
coming together to form a supergroup
some people loved it some people thought
it was fine and some people had an
alternate opinion that might be
qualified as a hot take we've got a
couple of those fellas right here with
us
first he's a writer of honest trailers
and an all-around swell guy
hello Joestar how it's always great to
be here and watch the master work oh
right back at you my friend and he's the
creator of honest trailers the host of
movie fights welcome to the show Andy
signor they doäôt I know I just never
know where to put my hands on the show
so guys you both watch the defenders
what's your take well my take is that
this show did not escalate properly let
me explain there I think the Netflix
shows started extremely strong daredevil
season 1 I loved it Jessica Jones I was
really into a great Marvel villain and
then daredevil season 2 it's starting to
show a little of its where it was still
fun Punisher was interesting but I just
science showed signs of growing too fast
and then Luke Cage Luke cages could I
was really excited the promos look great
I love the casting but it just started
seeming like they didn't want to put all
their money into that show they felt
like filler shows and then came artifice
and that was like really a trudge to get
through that show awful casting just
very generic show for me I thought
whatever Netflix has met throw
everything at the wall and make
defenders be the standout high budget TV
epic event they made less episodes than
usual for that run and instead it felt
like more of the same and it didn't have
the escalation I think the fans really
wanted those are great takes for an
episode called very polite takes okay
this is about hot takes Andy whoa and
the defenders was garbage wow it was it
was a terrible show that not only showed
that the Emperor may in fact have no
clothes but I mean this is a franchise
that is that considers it carries itself
as bulletproof and I think defenders
completely shattered that assumption and
now it's all just a downhill roll in
humans yeah a lot of people were hoping
that defenders would have the impact
that the Avengers had that Marvel did
all
the requisite work to work their way up
to the Avengers and we were all
satisfied we're like yeah we're loving
the MCU so you feel like knew they did
not I know and I agree because we all
were waiting for that Avengers moment is
how said and when we get instead Joe so
many scenes of two people talking
quietly in a cheap room a very nice
conversation in a Chinese restaurant so
many conversations of Chinese
restaurants and in the dojo and what
other room can we use again because a
lot of a lot of Star Wars sitting and
talking way too much sitting and talking
yeah you brought these people together
and it was weird the one episode I liked
was the webisode they all talked in a
Chinese restaurant you're allowed to
have one of those a season they get the
bottle episode and it's like you can
justify a bottle episode where you're
stuck in one location because they
finally met each other but it took four
damn episodes
yeah then to come together on a show
called the defenders and you should be
able to top a Chinese restaurant talking
episode like you should be able to top
that and they never do like nothing ever
really builds in this show we get some
sort of reminders of ever who everyone
is like oh Jessica Jones sure is
drinking and Matt sure is guilty and you
know Luke sure is a very attractive
badass but no one really gross mm-hmm
not even Danny grows and that felt like
the point of the show to me he's still
an idiot by the end yeah he still hasn't
like trick him to do the thing it's like
spoiler alert we're doing this late
because now people could talk about yeah
they also introduced this wonderful
villain of Sigourney Weaver I'm like
okay this will be interesting
and then again spoiler alert they kill
her off in the most unexpected plot
which I was just so bored by that there
was nothing new they gave me nothing new
this was the shining moment for me of
Mike hmm Netflix can fail here because
if they didn't see the the importance of
investing more in an offender series and
putting actually either doing half the
episodes I think if they had spent that
budget and dude five episodes we would
add a much different story and they
would have been able to actually put it
towards more action and actually get
them together quicker and cut a lot of
misty and whatever walk around having
are you sure you're doing the right
thing like how many times are we in the
freaking police station with her you got
to tell me something you got to trust me
on this misty
you got to tell me something Luke but
you got to trust me miss D all right
Iron Fist you got to tell me something
I'm an idiot
you're miss T voice is a little gravelly
but still sexy Yeah right how do you
feel about the hands plan with an acting
black sky and what was behind that door
that they were trying to get to more
like [ __ ] pal Wow Wow went there
look daredevil gave us hand ninjas
that's the only point of the hand is
just if you want to do something where
you have infinite disposable ninjas
that's what I want to see is just these
cool heroes fighting an infinite number
of ninjas and they couldn't even give us
that why can't you give me my ninja this
is a budget for it no they did not
which is ridiculous because as we saw
from the daredevil hallway scene it's a
stunt team of maybe six dudes and
they're just falling out of frame and
they're putting on different hats with
ninjas you're wearing a ninja mask just
fall out of frame and you're a new ninja
Joe I know from the beginning you've had
a bone to pick with Iron Fist yeah how
much did Iron Fist get under your skin
the interesting thing that I'll give to
the show was that they seemed very aware
yeah the fact that Iron Fist was a
disaster and almost like tried to make
the show about it but that doesn't
forgive it like if that would almost be
like in the prequels obi-wan being like
I know and it gets a huge baby but just
fix it just make him not a huge baby the
defenders really did though make me feel
like and re-watching the other seasons
in my head and I was like they weren't
that good were they it created doubt in
my mind as to whether our is this series
worth recommending to people because it
goes nowhere it's like Jessica Jones
daredevil season 1 I guess still
probably hold up a bit yeah but even I
feel like Jessica Jones gets a little
full of itself by the end I think that's
where it's starting to feel like I don't
know what to do with these shows anymore
they're trying to contain them in this
universe and make them or interact
together but then they don't really seem
to know how to do that the worst thing a
show can do is make you kind of go back
and question what came before it yeah
like if infinity war were to be so bad
that I go back and go man is the Marvel
formula overall just a lot worse than I
thought like our own Jenny Nicholson
once said one of my favorite things
about crimson film criticism she said
loving something blindly doesn't mean
you love it
or you just love it sadder and I thought
of that as soon as the defenders was
over the other way they did that which I
don't think we've touched upon is this
powers like what was so frustrating to
me was also now I've lost complete track
of who does what who's actually more
powerful than what and there is
something I think that's a disservice to
the fans and sort of the viewers would
like not be better on top of that the
scene with Luke Cage and Iron Fist was
kind of fun and when they first meet
each other and they don't know who they
are and they're trying to fight each
other and then he finally uses his fists
and then he's like whoa that was the
only good time I thought they did it and
then they just completely forgot about
it their Jessica Jones is like I don't
understand what she can do I don't
understand a little bit all they feel
like they're all are Luke Cage in a way
when her punches should be shattering
every there's every bone in your bodies
yes she's super strong I think this is
another place where the budget really
showed yeah with a series like this you
have an opportunity at the beginning of
every series to wipe the slate clean and
really knock this one out of the park
and they just they didn't take that
opportunity had all the tools this is a
great cast three out of four yeah yeah
three of them are fantastic and then one
of them is 90s Justin Timberlake ramen
here Amy Masterson yeah they had every
opportunity to really knock this out of
the park and they just didn't it kind of
farted along my negative reaction after
finishing defenders is that Marvel has
gotten to a point where they just assume
we're gonna like it because they put
they slapped a Marvel on it throughout
much of the other series and this series
Scott Glenn's character stick and other
characters were touting the battle for
New York do we feel like we received
that do we feel like we got a weird
earthquake at the beginning that was
very reminiscent of CW's arrow defenders
how dare and then we got a small fight
in a bone basement and if that was the
Battle of New York then that sucks
h-how'd you pointed out the flash
because it's true when they do a
four-episode arc like they did with last
year's alien invasion it was actually
really fun they like yeah I'm in they
help each other there's a point to it
that's what you want with a show like
that and so defenders had all the
ingredients and then they never really
this is the gritty Netflix street-level
show like I want to see r-rated gritty
Avengers you have you've been building
up to it and that just felt very soft
and boring you feel like you were sold a
false bill of goods at all stick to what
was cool of like you guys are like the
the gritty heroes yeah are you doing
good or bad it's unclear like you're all
of you of your inner demons and people
aren't sure whether the support you or
not and then you're gonna go cross a
line that maybe you shouldn't like these
are themes we don't really get to see
and love it and flash it even arrow and
in the movies like take advantage of
that and go there and then they don't
really want to go there it still feels
like they're making a network show on
Netflix we're just like come on Netflix
the hell you're allowed to make this
artery's yeah so there's no signs of it
stopping we're gonna get the punisher
we're gonna get more of these characters
what would you suggest to them going
forward punisher has an opportunity here
because it's just on its own it seems
like it's its own thing and the punisher
i feel like they at least have the
foresight to be like well we can't like
ABC family this one like we do my
defenders because it's it's the punisher
the hall h footage from punisher did
look really cool at Comic Con so I'm
excited about that but I think they
really need to do is say why why are we
making a second season of this beyond
the fact that we're supposed to because
people will watch because we have bought
the rights already and yeah just give me
a really strong story with these great
performers and also Finn gems I guess
whoa damn some hot tanks so how to get
burn burn what did you guys think about
all of those hot takes what did you
think about the defenders is anyone
going to come to the defenders defense I
think you might let us know in the
comments section below
I want to thank my good friend Joe star
our other am a pal handy signor thank
you for coming in and let us know how
you felt with some hot paste and thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye-bye